there broadly speaking there are two
categories of questions you'll get doing
that involve the equation of pop okay
the first one the simplest one looks
like this so maybe you should be
convinced that per second because you'll
have time to get all this the first
category is where they just changing the
acquaintance apart this is where we make
it nice and easy for you don't work out
what that question is you can guess you
can infer what the other kind is we give
you B we give you alpha we give you
gravity and then we say now you work out
the accreditor part so that takes a
little more work and we'll get to them
later on this exercise okay but if they
just give it to you you can just stop
answer your questions immediately right
so the first question is what is the
horizontal range now this is the picture
right you've got our parabola it starts
at the origin and then aggregate ball
legs on the ground
okay so the five horizontal range or
you're after is this other x value over
here right so that's why you can see
I've solved for y equals zero in keep
this my y equals zero this is a very
simple quadratic to do it so I factorize
there's my point of origin by putting
projection and there is where I land so
that is the horizontal range now Harry
must be a good question earlier you know
should you answer in words like this I'm
always going to encourage you if the
question is in words I think your answer
should also be in words but I know
sometimes you had a bit of a hurry would
it be okay if you just got to this point
and you said x equals 40 meters I think
that would get a past but I think this
is a better answer it is certainly a
clear answer okay so if you get your
puzzle to range and your next question
is you guys have a question from you
whatever I think it's where is the
what's the tallest was the highest
wavelength now because it's a parabola
which you now know because you have an
equation apart from all there's five
equations it's implicit but it's not
actually this is a parabola okay but
that is you know it is a parabola so you
can say well the highest point will come
at the axis of symmetry now you already
worked out where the end point is you
have to route 0:40 your axis of symmetry
is exactly halfway between it's x equals
20 you can pop that in and you get your
greatest - right there okay now then I
think they asked you for what the angle
is what is the initial angle at which
its final okay so that's why you can see
I need to bring in the derivative
because that's what tells me about the
gradient which is we're getting this
wrong now you just put in your initial
value like like so x equals zero because
that's where you get your you get this
value because you say 10 now 4 equals 1
now again yourself it's a pretty minor
thing but because at this point you've
done calculus I think your answer
strictly speaking here at this point
should be in radians because you're
doing calculus right but when they ask
for an angle of projection almost
certainly they actually want that be
degrees so that's why my answer is 45
degrees okay so might a point but it's
just kind of iffy when you do calculus
suddenly degrees just be very very
careful ok what's the expression
terrible alright so they then say uh
then they give you a point where what
sort of quarter tonight ten eight so
they say guy here's some point right a
ten comma eight and they say you love
this polish digital it this beautiful is
either going to go to the one at that
point or it's going to go above that
point and how you work out which is
weird
well you can take that x value and
substitute it in once you do that you
will find it's either below or above and
I think I found the boy yep there you go
it passes through seventh month which is
clearly below it mate okay at the last
piece you have to do this is the tricky
so much you shouldn't quickly look at
what lost my patient
we're like what exit I didn't see in
Genesis wow that was an amazingly lucky
again doing it they give you the general
equation path and then they say find the
velocity okay so they do that because
you have to prove it that's nice now a
lot you will say all I'm used to finding
variables like this no sorry closets
like this I take this value right and
I'm gonna need to put in an x and a y to
simplify that out right now usually like
we did when we got this
we frequently use initial conditions and
then it's kind of a knee-jerk reaction
used to equal zero whatever right now
when are you initially x equals zero and
y equals zero now you can pop that into
this equation get it resolved zero is
here and then zero is there and zero is
there yeah this is true sure enough 0
does equal 0 but not very useful for
your intended purpose what is your
intended purpose you need to find V so
whatever value you choose can't
eliminate V from this equation because I
still need that there right and you have
an abundance of choices from all your
earlier work for a value of x that goes
with a value of 1
I noticed this is one particular value
that's easier than all the rest would
you think would be the easiest to use
it's gonna be a horizontal rank now why
is that your horizontal range is good
I'm liking your horizontal range tells
you here we go
right it tells you this point here right
which we said was 40 comma zero now why
do you think I would like a point like
40 comma zero why might it be simple for
us because it has a zero in it this is
likely to be an integral if you can
iterate from zero to something it's nice
and simple
right so you can choose a different
point why don't we say the top was 20
comma 10 you can put that in you'll get
the right answer that's what buried in
right but if you choose 40 comma zero
your left hand side immediately comes 0
and then usually simplify out and you
will get your initial velocity like so